this man refuses to give up his vision
of peace now more than ever after the
attacks in paris
he's kali maroon chairman of the every
mosque every is a suburb of paris
colorful and multicultural
but it also has social tensions there's
a lot of dissatisfaction among the young
people i tell parents that they need to
watch out that their children don't
learn about islam from imam google
that's a false imam
young people should turn to a genuine
religious scholar
sit down for imam melroon spends lots of
time with kids it's a daily ritual
he knows about life on the fringes of
society having arrived in france in the
1970s as a guest worker
he says he's always been a friend of
mankind and his france is a welcoming
country
the three murdered police officers
represent france
they were a cross section of the country
one was arab one was white and one was a
black woman
that's typical for this kind of
indiscriminate terrorism
it affects everyone
supports the international campaign not
in my name which young muslims are now
supporting in france
they post photos and comments distancing
themselves from terrorism
and expressing their own principles
i don't like charlie hebdo because i
think the cartoonists often go too far
and hurt people's feelings
so i can't identify with charlie hebdo
but i'm against any form of violence and
i don't want people to kill in the name
of islam
those people aren't muslims
the majority of muslims have been
horrified by these recent acts of
terrorism
yet the muslim community in france is
under pressure
its members face discrimination and
prejudice on a daily basis
right-wing extremist groups rant about
an alleged islamization of the country
and characterize all observant muslims
as extremists
the jews used to be the main target of
the right-wing extremists
but now marine le pen is using
islamophobia to try to win the next
election
but she's a total hypocrite
she's two-faced
acting friendly one minute then doing
the opposite
hypocrisy
maroon works tirelessly in his fight
against fanatics of all camps he wants
to encourage understanding rather than
prejudice
and he can be proud he's been awarded
the french medal of honor for his
grassroots work at promoting peace
i know how much our muslim fellow
citizens are suffering right now
and i thank the chairman of the mosque
khalil maroon for his emphatic words
about the attacks
on the streets of france voices are
growing louder
the deep shock of the attacks has
resulted in france's population closing
ranks
hundreds of thousands of muslims were
among those marching to demonstrate
solidarity with the victims of the
terrorist attacks and their families
but that kind of closeness is far from
complete even within the muslim
community traditional and modern
theologians are often vehemently opposed
to each other
anthropologist malek chable himself a
muslim warns that such fractional
disputes are harmful when it comes to
enlightening the west about islam
it's high time that we reform everything
we must finally organize democratic
elections among muslims so that we have
a single elected grand imam
democratic we have to do things a bit
like the jewish community does them
and
israel
the chairman of the every mosque wants
to be a role model when it comes to
getting involved in social and
interfaith matters
we say
muslims be the eyes of society
you must prevent terrorism from being
able to spread
the events of last week have shown that
now more than ever muslims must be
vigilant in defending the values of
islam to prevent deep rifts within
france